Shaping a shallow round neck line
for a sweater back can be tricky.
There are only about one inch worth
of rows involved, but we'll knit three
separate sections to create that
nice round shape for the back neck.
Although I didn't add a lifeline in this
sample, I suggest you stop a few rows
before knitting your neck shaping
and scrap off the entire piece.
Then rehang the stitches and
continue knitting this way.
If disaster strikes, you'll be able to
rescue your knitting and start again.
Let's get started.
I'm going to use short row shaping for
the shaped shoulders, and at the same time
I'll work simple decreases
for the neck edge shaping
. I could short row the neck edge as well,
but for this one inch of shaping, it's
really too easy for me to get confused.
Now, you may not have this problem and I
suggest you try short rows on both sides.
If you like.
I'm on row 54 the carriage is on the right
and I'm putting the center 24 needles into
hold position.
I'll also hold the left side
needles as well for now.
Double check to make sure
the carriage is set to hold.
My pattern tells me to bind off three
stitches, but because I'm choosing to
short row, I'm going to unknit these three
stitches on this row and wrap that edge
stitch.
Does that make sense?
The working yarn is in position to bind
off those first three shoulder stitches,
but I'm going to hold them instead.
I'll knit to the left,row counter 55 and
following my pattern, I'll decrease one
stitch at the neck edge.
Now before I knit back, I'll put three
more needles in hold on that shoulder edge
now knit to the right and
I'll be on row counter 56.
Wrap that end needle.
We don't want any holes.
Notice that I've now bound off actually
held six stitches on the shoulder.
I'll continue to decrease
at the neck edge.
And knit to the left.
Row counter 57.
Actually, I decreased
a little quickly here.
We'll decrease another stitch.
Pay attention to your pattern, Sue, and
put three more needles in hold on the
shoulder edge.
I'll knit back to row counter 58.
Don't forget to wrap.
Knit to the left.
Row counter 59 even though my pattern is
telling me to bind off three stitches, I
really don't want to wrap near that
seeming stitch, so I'm going to only hold
two stitches this time.
Sometimes it's okay to break the rules,
especially when you make a mistake like I
just did.
Knit across and back.
Now because I chose to short row, I've
knit one extra row over just a few of
those little stitches and
that shouldn't be a problem.
We choose to short row
to have a smoother seam.
One extra row isn't going to hurt.
At this point, notice that there
are a bunch of wraps on the needles.
So I'm going to net one more row to
secure these reps and then scrap off.
Now you could scrap off without knitting
that extra row, but when you go to rehang
this edge to seam the shoulder, you'll
have stitches and wraps to pick up at the
same time.
This is not my idea of fun.
Knit an extra row rehang the stitches for
the shoulder seam and take out that row.
If it bothers.
You again, just one more row
isn't going to hurt anything.
You might also want to adjust your
shaping to match your row counts exactly.
If you're that kind of knitter and you
must have your row counts exact to the
pattern, go for it.
At this point, I'd rather have a nice
smooth seam rather than steric steps.
Okay.
We have one side shaped and scrapped off
and the other stitches are still in hold.
At this point, you have a choice.
You can keep your center stitches in hold
while you knit the second shoulder and be
sure to protect them so they don't get
damaged by the carriage going back and
forth.
But I chose to scrap off
those center stitches.
No real reason why I did it.
Just try it both ways
and see what you like.
We'll follow our pattern again
and work the shaping in reverse.
Reset the row counter to 54 check to
make sure your carriage is still in hold.
Push all the needles back into working
position and then following your first
shaping instructions.
Put three needles into hold position.
Knit across
and wrap that end needle.
Decrease one stitch and knit to the right.
Put three more needles into hold
knit across and wrap.
Decrease at the neck edge.
Three more needles in hold
for the shoulder shaping.
KNit left.
wrap,
decrease, one stitch at the neck edge.
You get the idea.
Just keep following your pattern and just
do the reverse of what you did on the
other side.
Knit that last row to secure
the wraps and scrap off.
Voila.
You're ready to continue
constructing your sweater.
Now notice that because I chose to
decrease instead of short rowing the
neckline edges, there is a bit of a
stair-step, but for back neck opening,
this isn't too bad.
Again, I suggest you try this exercise
both with decreases and short rows if you
like and see what you think.